[Musik]
hallo ihr Lieben wir machen heute
Teigtaschen ich persönlich finde der
Teigtaschen gehen immer und nachdem ich
euch auf Instagram mit meinem SATA Toast
angefixt habe habe ich mir gedacht ich
spende Idee mal weiter und mache richtig
leckere SATA Käse Teigtaschen da raus
falls ihr euch fragt was ist das ist so
eine Thymian Gewürzmischung gibt's
verschiedene Mischungen so wie man das
auch bei Currys zum Beispiel kennt jeder
hat seine eigene Mischung und
hauptbestandteil ist eben Thymian und
das ist in so einer leckeren Mixtur aus
weiteren Zutaten das ich kann es euch
gar nicht beschreiben vielleicht könnt
ihr mir mal den Gefallen tun für alle
die Satan noch nie probiert haben
einfach mal in die Kommentare schreiben
wie das schmeckt also wie könnte man es
beschreiben ich finde es einfach super
witzig es schmeckt orientalisch aber
auch nicht zu orientalisch also einfach
richtig lecker das nicht immer und ich
habe es immer auf Toast gemacht mit
Frischkäse und ganz typisch ist da auch
dass da Olivenöl mit dazu kommt das
könnte man da aber auch weglassen wir
blenden euch das Video am besten mal ein
so und ich mache jetzt weiter und starte
direkt mit meinem Teig ich gebe jetzt
nicht alles an Mehl rein ich behalte so
ein bisschen was zurück weil wenn einmal
drin ist ist zu spät und wenn der Tag
dann zu trocken ist dann ärgert man sich
und die ganz genauen Mengenangaben
schreibe ich euch ja sowieso wie immer
hier unten in der Infobox dann könnt ihr
euch das ganz einfach screenshotten
einkaufen und Nachmachen so ich benutze
heute Trockenhefe weil ich keine frische
Hefe da habe das einfach mit reingeben
Salz kann in dem Fall dann auch schon
direkt mit rein und ich habe mir jetzt
auch gedacht nicht nur in als Füllung
kommt da dran sondern auch was für die
Optik deswegen gebe ich jetzt hier zu
den trockenen Zutaten auch noch mein
Esslöffel mit dazu
[Musik]
eigentlich hätte ich früher auf die Idee
kommen können weil da ist ja auch Sesam
drin und zu Mark ist ja das Essigbaum es
gibt noch so eine ganz leichte Säure
aber so angenehm einfach
mal probieren ich verlinke euch auch
gerne in die Infobox und ich gebe jetzt
hier ein ganzes ein mit dazu und noch
ein Eiweiß weil ich das Eigelb später
zum Bestreichen brauche deshalb verwerte
ich das jetzt einfach das kommt jetzt
einfach mit dazu
so und ihr könnt das ganze Rezept auch
ohne Ei machen dann könnt ihr einfach
das Ganze also die Flüssigkeit an Milch
auffüllen das funktioniert auch ich
wollte gerne einen mit dazu geben weil
das den Teig einfach noch ein bisschen
fluffiger macht so und jetzt fange ich
an das zu kneten und gebe dann nach und
nach das Mehl mit dazu
[Musik]
so nach ein paar Minuten ist unser Teig
auch schon fertig also ihr merkt es halt
auch daran dass wenn ihr so anfasst und
dann nichts man den Fingern klebt
grundsätzlich ist das ein sehr feuchter
Teig aber der darf nicht kleben das ist
ganz wichtig und ich muss jetzt
eigentlich auch gar nichts mehr machen
die Maschine hat alles für mich erledigt
heute aber wir können das natürlich auch
mit den Händen verkneten aber was ich
jetzt schon mache ist dass ich mir den
Teig teile ich denke ich mache da so 24
ähm Teilchen raus die werde ich jetzt
schon mal durchteilen und dann unter
einem Geschirrtuch ca 45 Minuten dann
gehen lassen wenn ihr habt dann auch
gerne eine Stunde wenn ihr keine Zeit
habe ist ausnahmsweise auf 30 Minuten
möglich aber je länger der geht umso
fluffiger wird der
[Musik]
so ich habe mir jetzt Zeit genommen eine
Stunde später sind die Teiglinge richtig
schön fluffig aufgegangen ich denke aber
noch mal zu ich zeige euch jetzt die
schnelle und einfache Füllung so dafür
nehme ich mir wir nehmen jetzt double
cheese einmal Doppelrahmfrischkäse
so und dann nehmen wir noch Gouda oder
Emmentaler nee wir nehmen Triple cheese
ganz zum Schluss gebe ich noch
Mozzarella rein damit sie das richtig
schöne Fäden zieht auch noch und dann
kommt natürlich später noch unsere Haupt
Zutat mit rein und ihr braucht nichts
weiter an Gewürzen gar nichts das
erledigt alles ja ich habe gerade schon
erklärt was ist eine Thymian
Gewürzmischung mit auch noch mit drin
das wird alles schön geröstet in
Sonnenblumenöl und ähm ja deswegen haben
wir beschreiben kann
sagen
also
zum Frühstück
du kannst ja später mal im Test zeigen
wie man das morgens beim Frühstücken ist
dann Aufgaben für heute okay
[Musik]
so jetzt braucht ihr eigentlich gar kein
ausrollstab heute nehmt euch einfach so
ein aufgegangenen Teigling Breite wie so
ein bisschen mit den Händen das fühlt
sich so gut an gerade so dann gehen wir
ein bisschen was von unserer Füllung
dazu Mozzarella nicht vergessen und dann
werden wir das ganze auch schon
verschließen ich nehme heute übrigens
nicht das normale Backblech sondern ich
nehme meine Auflaufform und wenn ihr da
noch mal den Olivenöl Geschmack mit drin
haben möchte weil das ist wirklich
typisch also Olivenöl und SATA passt
einfach perfekt äh könnt ihr da auf
jeden Fall noch gutes Olivenöl einfach
und runter geben dann nimmt das da noch
mal den Geschmack an das mache ich
gleich auch
ich zeige euch das am besten mal also
ich verschließe jetzt einfach
ein bisschen in den Händen rollen und
das war's so und jetzt habe ich hier die
Auflaufform einkochte da kein Öl das ist
meine emaillierte Auflaufform die ist
auch super ähm was so anpappen angeht
also da habt euch eigentlich nichts an
aber geschmacklich ist einfach normal
geil mit dem Olivenöl so mein Pinsel
so und dann einfach reinlegen und hier
gerne noch mal 15 Minuten aufgehen
lassen wenn ihr Zeit habt zugedeckt
damit sie noch fluffiger werden
[Musik]
so zu guter Letzt rein für die Optik
also auch wieder kein Muss gebe ich hier
einfach nur Milch zum Eigelb also
generell das Bestreichen ist halt kein
Muss ich finde das Auge ist mit
geschmacklich tut sich da jetzt nichts
und dann bestreiche ich die noch oben
einfach nur mit dem Eigelb damit zur
Farbe abbekommen und sonst würde ich ja
jetzt immer noch irgendwie Sesam oder
Schwarzkümmel drauf machen aber dadurch
dass wir jetzt schon im Teig haben
brauche ich das gar nicht weil die sehen
optisch schon so richtig gut aus
ähm bei manchen zeigen ja aber dadurch
dass ich hier so viel Öl drin habe
glaube
[Musik]
so Hamza ich bin sowas von gespannt
richtig
cooles chinesisches Olivenöl
unten Olivenöl weil ich finde das musst
du schon irgendwie mit dazu weil das
passt einfach perfekt
von deiner Mama weil jetzt mal andersrum
ja okay
mit und die sind halt extrem soft ne die
sind richtig richtig
gut und jetzt zeige ich euch noch wie
man das eigentlich ist gerade war das
Oliven so gut es schmeckt das gut
natürlich das macht auf jeden Fall
unterschiedlich
das macht einen Unterschied
ist so toll und sowas aber es schmeckt
wirklich wenn man
das beste Beispiel
baguette in der Pfanne gemacht mit
Olivenöl das ist das danach gemacht mit
einem Olivenöl glaube ich auf dem
Supermarkt ne und meine ist nein das
hatte mit der Olivenöl besser geschmeckt
dann bist du dann meine meine
bezahlt dafür das ist einfach echt
ich finde die Kombi auch richtig geil
das ist normalerweise ist es ja alle
möglichen Schafskäse und Kartoffeln
eigentlich braucht man jetzt Fladenbrot
das habe ich jetzt nicht da aber sagen
wir mal Toast ne du hast eine Tod
so und dann tut man das in gutes
leckeres Olivenöl abtropfen lassen und
dann tut man das irgendwie jede Profi
dann tut man das Insert hat und so ist
man das zum Frühstück und ähm
übrigens dieses Videos vor gedreht wir
haben gerade den weiß ich nicht ersten
Februar und in sechs sieben Wochen dann
können wir nicht mehr mittags drauf los
essen
[Musik]
okay
das musst du auf jeden Fall mit Kamera
das musst du auf jeden Fall machen
und dann sind wir glaube ich wirklich
besser
hast du den satt
und das ist einfach noch fluffiger mit
richtig Käse auch richtig lecker so
und mein Kanal kostenlos abonnieren
nicht verpassen möchte jeden zweiten Tag
ein neues Rezept und dann würde ich mal
sagen bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]